my life has been pretty magical in the
last year not only did I get married and
buy a house but adopted the cutest darn
dog in the world I had an inkling that
the universe is smiling upon me but I
was just a theory with the upcoming
release of metric oh now I know that's a
fact all right that's an exaggeration
but metric o is still seemingly made
just for me it's a puzzle platformer
designed exclusively for the Vita that's
my favorite genre on my most used system
so you can see why I'm excited and
metric oh lives up to my high
expectations before I break down the
mind-bending mechanics take a moment to
appreciate the delicate visual design
it's just a lovely world to inhabit know
and the rousing soundtrack pulled me
deeper within its clutches
now under the task of explaining exactly
what's going on every screen has its own
rules that you must come to grips with
platforms move based on your actions
simple enough right well not quite
pillars may rise out of the earth when
you walk forward or maybe jumping causes
under reach the heavens who knows so you
have to experiment it's a great concept
because every stage gave me a mini
epiphany I would do the dance in the
beginning seeing how I could change the
environment and then after a couple
failures something would click and I
would breeze through to the end there
aren't many moments in real life when I
get to feel like a genius but that
feeling frequently hit me when playing
metric oh i played through two and a
half worlds and was completely immersed
throughout magico should be out in the
next few months or so and i'll be
hitting that download button as soon as
it becomes available if you enjoy having
your mind blown I suggest you do the
same
you